beginnen wollen wir heute abend mit
jasmin und alexander denn während wir
alle schliefen und vier uhr morgens
waren die beiden polizisten im einsatz
um uns zu schützen um uns vor dem bösen
zu bewachen und um ihrer pflicht nach zu
gehen um vier uhr morgens stoppen sie
also bei kusel ein verdächtiges auto und
werden dann bei ihrer pflichterfüllung
brutal erschossen die beiden gaben ihr
leben für den rechtsstaat für unsere
gesellschaft für uns und deshalb halten
wir am anfang dieser sendung einen
moment inne und verneigen uns vor jasmin
und alexander
[Musik]
diese morde machen uns fassungslos
es fehlen jetzt zwei von uns wir können
es nicht begreifen und verstehen dass
alex fehlt das auch jasmin fehlen das
ist ein verlust es tut weh beide sind
durch nichts und niemanden zu ersetzen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja haben den verlust zu beklagen zwei
junge menschen eine junge
polizeikommissar anleiter werden und ein
polizeioberkommissar die das ganze leben
noch vor sich hatten es ist einfach nur
schrecklich und traurig
[Musik]
jeder dieser uniform stecken menschen
wir haben gefühle wir trauern wir freuen
uns wir sind einfach menschen
[Musik]
natürlich sind wir in gedanken besonders
bei jasmins und alexanders familien und
angehörigen zwei zahlen möchte ich ihnen
heute abend noch mit geben die uns alle
unbedingt zum nachdenken bringen müssen
alle 15 minuten wird in deutschland ein
polizist attackiert und insgesamt wurden
mehr als 80.000 polizisten im
vergangenen jahr opfer einer straftat
nach den tödlichen schüssen am
wochenende hat mir ein polizist
geschrieben wir schützen die
gesellschaft aber wer schützt eigentlich
uns und das ist eine frage auf die wir
als gesellschaft und vor allem die
politik dringend eine antwort finden
muss